students at the University of
california-berkeley held a day of
protest on Friday to demand the creation
of additional safe spaces for
transgender and non-white students and
during the protest they created a human
chain to prevent white students from
getting to class some Asian students
were also blocked from getting to class
but Hispanic Latino black students were
allowed through and were allowed to go
to class and I'm gonna play a little bit
of video where you can actually hear
protestors shouting go around to white
students who try to get through this
blockade and students of color are
greeted with let him through let her
through let them through we have video
let's take a look at that
yeah I was just wondering like what so
what's it do you know one protester
actually complained that there were too
many white students in classrooms saying
quote when you walk into a class what's
the majority in there this is
problematic to me not only because it
doesn't account for racial differences
in the population at large not only does
it not consider that blaming individual
white students who are already at the
school solves absolutely nothing but
it's problematic to me because according
to UC Berkeley's own website only one in
four students in the incoming 2015
freshman class was actually white which
makes this entire charade particularly
misguided many white and Asian students
forced to actually go through like the
woods essentially if it was a dirt path
through brush in order to make it to
class while the protesters were shouting
go around and it's not just against
white people it's against white and
Asian students according to that article
and that sort of changes the dynamic I
got one email from from someone saying
David the issue is not necessarily just
race and minorities versus non
minorities because Asians are minorities
but Asians maybe are seen as more
successful in American society so maybe
there's a different feeling there but
we're also gonna block the Asians from
getting through it really makes no sense
and we could talk a lot about the so
called ideal immigrant that many Asian
communities represent in the US but can
you imagine that if the students blocked
from getting to class actually filed a
lawsuit on the basis of having their
title six rights violated because if you
look at the 1964 Civil Rights Act title
six prohibits discrimination on the
basis of race color and other
characteristics at any program that
receives any federal financial
assistance
like for example UC Berkeley does that
could actually happen here yeah there
are some P
who are of the opinion that reverse
racism just doesn't exist and of course
it's a much less prevalent issue but
it's out there I just call it racism I'm
either you're discriminating on the
basis of race or you're not and this
idea of reverse racism is so bogus to me
and when you look at gender equality to
of course some issues negatively affect
men but the bulk of it negatively
affects women Martin Luther King and so
many others who fought for equality
would see this would be my guess and
they would say well hold on a second
what exactly are you doing by blocking
white students are you are you showing
them what it was like at some prior
point because now non-white students
aren't blocked from going to class so
what what is it exactly that you're
trying to do are you trying to wake
people up to what was the experience of
black students before the 1964 Civil
Rights Act because I just don't know I
always try to be as pragmatic as
possible with these issues and I don't
know what blocking white students is
going to teach them today in terms of
what the issues are that are trying to
be brought to light and let me remind
you also that there is a demand being
made here for the creation of safe
spaces segregated by race where white
people are not allowed which we've
covered what would be the punishment if
white students formed a chain to block
non-white students from getting to class
what would be the reaction if white
students created a no Brown people
allowed safe space on campus it would
rightly be very negative and some will
hear me say this and I'll say well the
difference David is that the white
students aren't oppressed but the other
students are I'll remind you that only
one out of four students in the incoming
UC Berkley 2015 freshman class was white
I don't get this Pat I don't know what
they're hoping to achieve by
inconveniencing realistically
individuals that are already overworked
stressed out and debt ridden I don't see
the wind